mais frédéric ottawa se préoccupe aussi
beaucoup des victimes de ces actes
criminels ça date pas d'hier d'ailleurs
non en fait ça a commencé officiellement
1988 sous l'ère de brno l'année un
gouvernement progressiste conservateur
et à l'époque il avait décidé de signer
avec tous les ministres de la justice de
toutes les provinces
la déclaration canadienne des principes
fondamentaux de justice relatifs aux
victimes de la criminalité en 2003 a été
mise à jour sous le gouvernement libéral
chrétien mais ce qui est important c'est
que c'est juste une déclaration
donc ça ça veut dire que dans le fond il
n'y a pas eu de droits supplémentaires
garantie qui ont été offerts aux
victimes vers lui est arrivé avec une
charte des victimes oui une charte en
fait qui est vraiment très très récente
l'a en fait la majorité des éléments de
cette cette charte ont été mis en
vigueur le 23 juillet 2015 alors ça
offrant fait plusieurs droits congrès
con ce congrès pour les victimes d'abord
il ya un droit à l'information c'est à
dire qu'ils doivent avoir un accès assez
clair et facile à toutes les données du
dossier qui concerne la victime
il ya également un droit important c'est
celui de la protection qui garantit
c'est à dire qu'évidemment on veut
éviter toute intimidation toute menace
on pense bien sûr à la sécurité des
témoins il y aussi et ça c'est
probablement un droit qui est vraiment
centrale dans cette charte c'est le
droit de participation c'est à dire que
la victime se retrouve un peu au centre
des procédures légales devant les
tribunaux donc la victime peut faire une
déclaration peut faire part de ses
inquiétudes par exemple au niveau du
processus elle peut apporter aussi une
photo de la victime
elle peut également assister aux
demandes de mise en libération sous
conditions et de libération
conditionnelle et puis enfin le
quatrième droit c'est celui qui concerne
le droit de demander un dédommagement
alors elle peut en quelque sorte aller
devant les tribunaux pour que celui ci
ordonne en fait aux criminels de payer
toutes les pertes financières qui ont
été encourus par le cayman messine
charte quand même critiqué oui en fait
il ya plusieurs experts juridiques qui
disent d'abord bombay c'est ce sont les
provinces et les territoires qui vont
devoir administrés en fait les impacts
de cette charte et d'une province à
l'autre il ya des opinions qui divergent
et aussi des moyens pour mettre en
pratique cette charte à qui divergent il
ya également le côté un peu plus
prévention qui n'existe pas en fait là
dedans les gens disent on devrait
peut-être mettre plus d'argent dans
l'aide directe aux victimes par le biais
de meilleur financement pour les
organismes
qui soutiennent ces gens là et puis
aussi il ya tout l'aspect juridique qui
vient peut-être encore davantage
engorger les tribunaux c'est à dire que
bon il ya des démarches qui vont devoir
être fait par ses victimes donc encore
une fois on rajoute d'autres états et on
sait les tribunaux n'ont déjà pas mal
sur l'assiette alors évidemment on verra
ce que ça va se faire l'efficacité
réelle de cette chape parce que c'est
quand même relativement nouveau depuis
le 23 juillet de cette année seulement
ces lignes mais merci beaucoup frédéric
c'est ce qui met fin donc à notre
dossier de ce soir sur l'état du canada
merci